[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at sonos i say good friends
because i've been using sonos products
long before they were a sponsor 18 years
before they were my sponsor i love the
sonos i have it all throughout my house
i could play a different song in each
room of the house i could play a ryan i
could play some mazzy star just to chill
in my bedroom i could play some duran
duran
in the living room maybe the outside i
could have a party mode there's so much
you could do with sonos
and it's just they're beautiful subtle
pieces
of sound equipment if you will
uh you know many are just the speaker
itself so all you need is a speaker to
resonate throughout the room with a
beautiful sound
they have really designed these things
amazingly uh
sonos rome is the ultra portable smart
speaker this new rome speaker have you
heard of this ryan uh yes well the sonos
roam is the ultra portable smart speaker
that allows you to bring the sonos
experience everywhere you go rome weighs
less than a pound folks and its premium
durable design makes it a perfect
perfect asset for the home and for on
the go so when you're home rome connects
to your wifi network and the rest of
your sonos system and then automatically
pairs with your phone on bluetooth when
you're on the go for a seamless
experience using automatic true play
tuning roam smartly adapts to your
surroundings and whatever you're
listening to and creates sound that's
astonishingly detailed and perfectly
balanced control rome using the app
apple airplay 2 or your voice with
amazon alexa or google assistant with
sonos you could start with one speaker
and expand your system over time like i
did all sonos speakers connect over
wi-fi so you can group speakers in
different rooms and play music like i
said throughout your entire home sonos
is wonderful if you haven't tried it
it's it's it's the gift that keeps on
giving and it's the holidays now and i
trust me you're going to thank me you're
going to write me and say hello at
what is it hello at inside you podcast
is that what it is yeah hello at inside
you podcast you're going to email me
you're going to say wow sonos really is
badass it is it's a badass product i've
had this for years i really encourage
you to try it um they're inexpensive and
they do what you need you don't have to
have these bulky speakers and all this
crap around your house just get a sonos
and it's so easy just go to sonos.com to
learn more you're listening to inside of
you with michael rosenbaum i hope you're
enjoying your week i hope thanks for
listening thanks for tuning in there's
so many freaking podcasts out there but
you choose this one or
maybe uh you're tuning in for the guest
but regardless i'm glad you're tuning in
and i hope that you continue to listen
and maybe subscribe after the podcast is
over we've had a lot of great guests i
think what you get here with this
podcast is intimate conversations real
conversations
it's not like two actors are talking
about actory [ __ ]
um i like to get deep and uh i like to
uh talk about real real things mental
health and and all that stuff and
careers and
you know what makes people tick facing
adversity all that stuff so if you like
the show and you hear that noise in the
background that's uh that's the gardener
and uh he wanted to be included in this
podcast
so uh ryan good to see you good to see
you too yeah it's always a treat uh i
know you've had a day i've had a day
yeah we both kind of
we're out of it we're kind of going
through the motions today it sort of
felt like when i walked in yeah just
feel like it feels like you're going
through the motions and uh
but hey man say your gratitude's every
day that's what gets me through just
waking up and saying hey i'm grateful
i'm alive here today folks we're live
we're doing it we're really doing it as
my friend tom lally says we're doing it
dude we're really doing it
just continue doing it man for me all
right do it and do it for you
uh i'd like to say before we get into
this great guest anthony michael hall um
i have a stage it two performances
coming up november 20th 2 p.m and 6 p.m
pacific standard time you can go to
sunspin.com the name of the band is
sunspin we have two shows ryan 2 p.m 6
p.m
virtual shows you could watch you could
bid tip whatever you want and just
prizes and zooms
to be won to be had
it's a lot of fun my my band partner rob
danson and i in fact tom lally my old
band member from left on laurel is going
to join us so november 20th get tickets
you can go to stageit.com or sunspin.com
and also
uh briefly i'd like to mention a charity
that i'm a part of echoes of hope
for the next month or two
echoes of hope is hosting a holiday
event for under-resourced children teens
young adults roughly 300 students will
be supported this december and if they
want to purchase a gift or two if you
guys would like to purchase a gift or
two you could visit our wish list on
amazon by going to at our echoes of hope
that's at
our
echoes of hope on social media these are
students who a lot of times do not have
the family so they oftentimes spend the
holidays alone and it can be very lonely
time for them so we host a holiday party
to make the holiday season special for
them visit
echoesofhope.org to learn more there's a
bunch of different options for giving on
the donate page so i'd like to just a
little shout out to echoes of hope my
wonderful charity that i'm on the board
for
and uh
if you want to follow us by the way or
write a review please do so please
subscribe and ryan tell them the handles
they could follow us on the instagram
they can go to at inside of you podcast
on instagram and facebook and at inside
of you pod on twitter
that is correcto mundo that's it that is
right um
yes i appreciate all you guys i
appreciate all my lovable patrons who uh
give to the podcast a little bit more
and it helps the podcast survive so i
could pay amazing people like ryan and
jason and bryce
and uh all you do is go to patreon.com
inside of you p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon dots
dot com slash inside of you you can give
back there's also different tiers and
things that you can get and enjoy and
it's become a big family people become
friends there's a lot of people that
have really united and become
lifelong friends and it means a lot to
me and it means a lot to me that they uh
they donate and they give back to the
show and if you feel like doing so feel
free patreon.com inside of you
right now this guest is uh i was excited
to talk to him anthony michael hall uh i
mean name a movie vacation 16 candles
breakfast club weird science uh johnny b
good edward scissorhands in his new
movie
uh halloween kills with jamie lee curtis
directed by david gordon green i'm very
excited um
it's a really fun movie it's really fun
action-packed that's perfect for the
holiday
you gotta see it uh i really enjoyed
talking to him and he was open and i was
nervous because
i like to geek out and i like to talk
about you know the old movies and the
old the old days and
what'd you think
uh i think you restrained yourself i
think it was good i think he was happy
to talk about everything which was cool
yeah yeah he really opened up i asked
him some some good [ __ ] i think you're
going to enjoy this and please spread
the word to subscribe to the podcast and
without further ado
let's get inside of anthony michael hall
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience we're talking about age right
now we just uh we're here with mike
we're here with anthony michael hall but
you like mike you go as much you do bro
yeah
your whole life you go mike yeah
now it's like the bob version of
whatever my three names is well it just
sounds so easy right yeah you want
people going anthony michael hall yeah
yeah you want it's mike i'm just mike
that's it
you know long name short story
yep is this is this your first horror
film
halloween kills this is you know what i
did i did a zombie flick um
about 10 years ago with daryl hannah and
and i worked with this company the
asylum dude sharknado and oh yeah great
they were a lot of fun but that was just
i don't even i still don't know what
happened it took like two and a half
weeks it was one of those
right yeah
uh but this one dude i've never been
more pumped
we shot this movie two years ago
in wilmington north carolina and
everybody was [ __ ] great um david
gordon green
danny who does mostly comedy and danny
mcbride who i've you know i've
auditioned for me too
yeah and he's a great guy but you don't
think of these guys as writing horror or
directing horror exactly and but when
you watch like all my friends and i for
holly i'm a big horror movie fan if you
haven't noticed by all the [ __ ]
horror movies in here
but like
we were watching all the halloweens and
i've noticed
with the exception of a couple they're
mostly [ __ ]
they're not that gr they're not really
good movies but then all of a sudden it
turned with
david gordon green's movies that's how i
felt like it just all of a sudden the
quality is like well where did this come
from yeah let's tell a story and let's
uh it just got better and better so it's
got to be fun to be a part of that like
that creative crew definitely and when
this came up two years ago i'm with
these great guys untitled jason weinberg
and mitch mason they called me
and i just initiated i said listen i'd
love to get together with david meet
with him
he came to town because those guys live
in charlotte don't care so you wanted to
you wanted to get with him first yeah
you you learned this guy and you wanted
to meet him totally so before the uh
before i did the screen test i met with
him on la cienega somewhere a hotel he
was staying at and he was just a great
guy man he shows up he's wearing like a
bob sega t-shirt talking on first name
basis with the bartender right and he
was just super chill and he we talked
about it we talked about his process
and how he and danny move back east with
their you know with their families and
their wives and they just kind of
regrouped
but also he mentioned how they set their
life up they did all these great shows
on hbo that we all loved you know he's
back coming down
vice principal all that stuff i mean
great work
and then uh at this point they had i
think halloween was out for about a year
or so
so uh you know that was it and then
after that i did the screen test that
went in just so you you auditioned still
i did but i just met with david first
which was great because we had about an
hour to kind of shoot the [ __ ] and just
talk about process and what he wanted to
do and what his objectives were and the
whole thing great guy man he actually
reminded me a lot of john hughes mike
really yeah dude because he's super
chill very down to earth very easy going
and even when we got on the set his
process was great man he was very
collaborative truly like kept the
dialogue going got ideas from everybody
he's not upset so you had an idea oh
let's try it oh yeah yeah
and also like john it's that thing of
you work with so many directors two
great ones um you do two or three takes
the way it's written and then we digress
you know if it's if it's cool if not you
move on you know but he was great man he
was really great geez is it have you
seen the movie oh yeah it's [ __ ] it's
kick-ass i love it is it violent
incredibly
probably more than the other 11.
yeah yeah yes not that i'm saying i love
violence but when it comes to what we
want right
that's why we have rooms like this
but but by the way when you're watching
a halloween movie you want to see the
kills you want to see this [ __ ] and you
never see them like it got weaker and
weaker as the series went along so now
we see a lot of deaths and listen people
love this guy meyers is i mean i thought
there were about 20 of these films
relative to freddie and you know and
nightmare and all these things
incredible how do you win when the when
the hero's the villain and he just goes
off dude it just meyers is going i don't
want to spoil anything but he just goes
right the [ __ ] off
dude look what he got me
look what he brought me he brought me a
halloween kill shirt i got one from ryan
too i got one for you do you really yeah
yeah with anthony on the shirt there
yeah
do you play a badass in it
okay so here's the thing in the in the
mythology of of the series in the 78
film
43 years ago kyle richards and brian i
don't know the cat's last name he they
were the two kids tommy and lindsey that
that jamie lee babysat
so there's an arc there it's interesting
so in the original film his his
character was bullied by la elam one of
the other kids
and uh he's also the one who says to
jamie lee in the original film you can't
kill the boogeyman right so he's kind of
like starts that whole mythology
so it's really cool listen the last one
was phenomenal it's great made 255
million dollars they did a great job
so this picture takes up right where the
other one left off like it picks up
halloween night they've just set him on
fire and of course he exits the fire and
comes after the town of course so yeah
and you see you and the town kind of
forges together that's right and it's
kind of all
[ __ ] fest well here's what's happening
here's what's great yeah so in this one
the movie opens we shot this really cool
ball uh bar called the rusty nail right
in wilmington perfect yeah um and the
movie opens it's the same night and and
all the uh the locals and the neighbors
have gathered together and they're kind
of commiserating about
having been survivors and victims and
all that
and then he cuts loose then it comes up
on the tv local news
meyers uh mars is on the loose again and
then it kicks off from there and it just
kicks ass man it's really great i'm
excited about this yeah man i want you
to see it you're gonna love it dude well
we have to watch so in order we have
like right now we have two rob zombies
and then we go into the david gordon
green which i've seen the first one but
we then we're gonna watch it right
through hollywood kill so we're gonna
we're gonna be watching this great by
the end of next week i'll have all of
them oh good good so i urge you guys to
watch it it's halloween for god's sakes
yeah it's anthony michael hall it's
david gordon green it's it's it's you
know it's gonna be a lot of fun i look
at all this stuff by the way the test
screen when you test screen
for
and you've tested green many times in
your life yeah we all have yeah what is
is it just you and david gordon green
and some producers is it what are they
no you know what you know
jason blum's brilliant right so he set
up his office it's great it's on in the
mid it's on melrose i think or olympic
all the way almost towards downtown got
a great office his whole company is
there obviously it's a universal company
but
so i went there did the audition with
the casting ladies that are set up there
in office right
um and just you know how it is man you
just prepare do your thing and just lay
it out there are you still good with
lines
are you getting old now i got readers
now i have readers it's great you got
the readers sure no contacts you got the
readers i got the readers
the weekly i'm walking with the readers
on my head ryan you'll see kid you've
got 20 years to get your 50s
he's you son of a [ __ ] you're right
it's good to be young yeah yeah enjoy
that dark hair yeah exactly christopher
reeve over here with the dark hair
uh
no but it was just great bro so i just
really went all in you know i just have
because that's the thing like i don't
know how you work i want to hear about
your process for me
if it's a comedy or something dramatic
or whatever you just make the audience
you're i mean the crew your first
audience so same thing in the context of
an audition right it's the women or the
gentleman in the in the room sometimes
as you know they're great directors they
can really be helpful
so we just had a you know a couple of
scenes that were in the film and i just
brought you know brought it did whatever
because you have to go nuts at all oh
yeah totally like where you just lose
your [ __ ] you got to see them we're
gonna have to do a part two schedule
schedule a part
two i love hearing this stuff i love
hearing about what you do in audition
and you just let go are you are you good
at letting go yeah man i think it was
important for this because i the thing
that i loved and i realized when i got
to wilmington is that david you know he
had this kind of heroes part for me
david and danny gave this great role and
jamie lee and jason blum
so tommy is kind of like the eye of the
storm man he kind of goes after you know
myers and he just like i told you the
way the movie opens but in fairness to
all the other actors michael it's a
great art that he gives us all everybody
goes okay [ __ ] this we're going to unify
we're going to fight we're going to go
forward and
nobody has an ark in halloween movies
yeah
no you're just me
yeah anybody has an arc you just set up
to be carnage
that c-a-r
you know i i look at this i look at your
body of work and it's it's crazy i know
you've heard a million times but like
breakfast clubs 16 candles weird science
edward scissorhands pirates of silicon
valley which as bill gates you were just
[ __ ] james i remember seeing that
going this guy should be in everything
you know uh 61 when you play yd4 dead
zone the series you worked with my
friend sean piller great guy we have
mutual friend sean right guy he got to
direct an episode uh you know you've
done so much now is it do you how much
do you hate
talking about the past going into like
the past because i mean it's part of
your part of the present you know what
michael i've always been open to it i
embrace it because had i not worked with
hughes as a kid i wouldn't be sitting
here man so i'm always like just the
opposite man i'm happy to discuss john
hughes i mean the guy was a genius
when we were kids i was you know he was
like a big brother me yeah you yeah i
loved him man i still miss him really i
do i i want to get into all that stuff
like your mom your mom raised how long
is this is this three hours no it's less
than an hour i can't talk more than an
hour
ten minutes in i'm middle aged i don't
know how long are you already hungry no
i'm good just get good the coffee's not
enough
but life is good
look up in the sky it's the finance
super app
invest with powerful tools and unmatched
automation borrow with some of the
lowest rates or spend your hard-earned
cash from their secure digital checking
account m1 finance does it all
all with a few taps in their sleek
modern app it's no wonder money
investopedia and yahoo finance are
raving about this app or that hundreds
of thousands of investors have trusted
over five billion dollars in assets on
the platform they say you shouldn't
always go with the flow but this tidal
wave of cash and savvy financiers
might be on to something
plus get a 30 bonus to your m1 invest
account when you get approved and fund
it with a thousand dollars within your
first 14 days it's so simple go to m
that's amazon michael
slash m1finance.com of you to get
started that's m the number one finance
dot com investing involves risk
including the risk of loss borrowing on
margin can add to these risks rates may
vary terms and conditions apply inside
of you is brought to you by brooke
lennon uh i'll tell you what when it
comes to
comfort uh you're looking at comfort
right here you see how i dress
always comfortable my house is very
comfortable i like people to be
comfortable in my house i like to be
comfortable in my bed
brooke linen is there brook linen works
directly with manufacturers to make
luxury available directly to you without
the luxury level markups so you get
their amazing array of products at a
reasonable price they're so confident in
their core products that they'll come
with a 365 day warranty and fans are
confident too they've received over 75
000 5 star reviews and counting so give
yourself the comfort refresh you deserve
and get it for less at brook lenin go to
brookelinen.com and use promo code
inside to get twenty dollars off with a
minimum purchase of one hundred dollars
that's brooke linen b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n
dot com and enter promo code inside for
twenty dollars off with a minimum
purchase of one hundred dollars that's
brookelinen.com
promo code inside inside of you is
brought to you by my good friends at
sonos i say good friends because i've
been using sonos products
long before they were a sponsor 18 years
before they were my sponsor i love the
sonos i have it all throughout my house
i could play a different song in each
room of the house i could play a ryan i
could play some mazzy star just to chill
in my bedroom i could play some duran
duran
uh in the living room maybe the outside
i could have a party mode there's so
much you could do with sonos
and it's just they're beautiful subtle
pieces of sound equipment if you will
uh you know many are just the speaker
itself so all you need is a speaker to
resonate throughout the room with a
beautiful sound
they have really designed these things
amazingly uh
sonos rome is the ultra portable smart
speaker this new rome speaker have you
heard of this ryan uh yes well the sonos
roam is the ultra portable smart speaker
that allows you to bring the sonos
experience everywhere you go rome weighs
less than a pound folks and its premium
durable design makes it a perfect
perfect asset for the home and for on
the go so when you're home roam connects
to your wi-fi network and the rest of
your sonos system and then automatically
pairs with your phone on bluetooth when
you're on the go for a seamless
experience using automatic true play
tuning rome smartly adapts to your
surroundings and whatever you're
listening to and creates sound that's
astonishingly detailed and perfectly
balanced control roam using the app
apple airplay 2 or your voice with
amazon alexa or google assistant with
sonos you could start with one speaker
and expand your system over time like i
did all sonos speakers connect over
wi-fi so you can group speakers in
different rooms and play music like i
said throughout your entire home sonos
is wonderful if you haven't tried it
it's it's it's the gift that keeps on
giving and it's the holidays now and i
trust me you're going to thank me you're
going to write me
and say hello at what is it hello inside
to you podcast
is that what it is yeah hello at
insidepodcast you're going to email me
you're going to say wow sonos really is
badass it is it's a badass product i've
had this for years i really encourage
you to try it
they're inexpensive and they do what you
need you don't have to have these bulky
speakers and all this crap around your
house just get a sonos
and uh it's so easy just go to sonos.com
to learn more
but your mom raised you
she did i grew up in manhattan new york
city
my mother remarried when she was a
single mom until i was about 12 and she
married my stepfather who was a great
guy when he passed on a couple years ago
my father sorry thank you brother yeah
and uh tom jostero my stepfather so he
was a great guy so you know i had the
benefit of kind of both i was the son of
a single mom i also had a nuclear family
that kind of thing east coast upbringing
new york city my company is manhattan
films and and i've been developing
projects for years um you know working
on different things that i'm trying to
set up
so i i consider new york a great teacher
man that's why yeah it was everything to
me was really because i sucked in school
how were you in school right were you
any good bees
barely i was c's and d's that was i was
colorblind
i couldn't keep my [ __ ] together i
didn't think i was going to amount to
much of anything thank you
i my combined score my sat i think was
400 it's embarrassing it's kind of but
it doesn't mean did you mean [ __ ] when
you were growing up did you think you
were dumb did you feel dumb no i didn't
feel dumb i just was very i i couldn't
deal with school it just bore the [ __ ]
out of me it was cool to meet girls and
and go to gym and lunch and that was
about it did you get girls at a young
age oh i had some dates really yeah
because you know you watch your persona
as a young kid on and you're like this
guy's funny he plays a geek just
amazingly he's lovable but did you milk
that was that kind of like you were the
funny guy i don't know if i milked it i
mean i think i just had fun i was one of
these kids like i don't know who you
were growing up but i was doing shows
for my family you know what i mean i do
i'd imitate my aunts and uncles and and
play funerals and weddings and you know
what i mean so that's how you start
serious no i swear to god you know never
having been as a stand-up
that's how i think i started my family
definitely man i was imitating aunts and
uncles and that's what i was doing were
you same thing right my parents would go
out to dinner and they'd come home and
they'd say how was snl and i would go oh
well you know tommy fenegan uh i would
say goes and do the sketches right or i
would do and i would do all the sketches
yeah you look absolutely marvelous i
would do that my daddy was telling me
fernando it's better to look good than
to feel good and i would do the church
lady hello again it's the church lady
this is a church chat and i would do
that i would reenact it
and i think my parents just thought
what's wrong with i don't know what's
what's going on with him yeah this is
the only thing he can do no i'm with you
man in the 70s i remember like you'd
have to stay up late to watch us and
element it was like a treat you know so
yeah i grew up watching all that that
first cast i mean i was very young i'm
53 now
but it meant so much to be grown by the
way that's young thanks brother come on
53 is young no it is it is young i
didn't say it was old he's just jumping
in he's not sure that that's yeah well
i'm almost there i'm almost there you're
right there no but honestly you know it
is it was a very important show you know
and and i've always loved comedians and
stand-ups i mean my heroes growing up
were carlin richard pryor oh yeah then i
studied lenny and you know what i mean
and i and i have nothing but love for
comics man that's a tough life it is it
is but i love them so snl was just a
great experience i mean the year i was
unsucked but it was a great great one
what do you mean i saw i was watching an
old clip of when you guys were doing the
armpit farts and you're like you're
reviewing the book with robert downey jr
and you're sitting there going yeah this
guy was pretty much
right and the writing is pretty much
thank you you know he's good at that
yeah and you're doing armpit farts and
he's made and i just thought it was
hilarious
that was my best [ __ ] at 17. that's all
i could come up with but i hear that you
were you said this in a recent interview
that you were scared as [ __ ] the entire
time oh totally for the reasons because
of the context i gave you before you
know it meant so much to me and then the
eddie murphy years i'm in high school
watching him and then episcopal and and
crystal after that i loved all those
guys man so after i agreed to the show
and i got the you know the call from
lauren what year was that 85 right after
i'd done weird science and it was just
incredible remember saying yes and then
walking around the city like what the
[ __ ] did i just but most people don't
usually lauren hires people when they're
nobodies yeah so all of a sudden you've
got a couple of hit movies and now
they're bringing young snl isn't that
odd i had the good fortune of working
for him like many of us obviously it's
an institution now four decades and
running he's an incredible guy you know
he really knows his stuff so it was a
great training ground and yeah you're
right usually comics or or or people
that do second city or citizens upright
brigade you know improv actors so i felt
very fortunate i wasn't lost on even as
a kid but uh just a great experience man
it's fun even when it's even when you
don't have a great sketch it's great man
it's a lot of fun what was it like like
the days leading up when you're in
rehearsal when you're doing all these
things are you still are you nervous
every day well let me tell you the
schedule first of all we come in on
monday i'm sure you've talked to people
who have been all right i want to hear
it yeah so you come in on monday you
start writing
you start pairing off and kind of going
into people's cubicles not unlike 30
rock that environment right
and then the show's written in the next
two days everybody works around the
clock they would shed they do their
thing they write sketches wednesday at
like noon you turn in your sketches
and you are you writing it this year i
was i was how old are you 17 17. you're
already writing yeah
because i realized no one gave a [ __ ]
and if i didn't you know i wouldn't
perform yeah but what was really cool
was lauren fostered this environment
where he would set you know like go
speak to don novello you know or go go
he would perish with these legendary
great writers man so we wouldn't you
know he would encourage that process and
we'd have to kind of make the rounds and
go around you know so anyway back to the
schedule we shoot we write monday
through wednesday you turn in the
sketches
and then we do a read-through about
three o'clock and then what what lauren
does is he invites the cast and crew in
and he kind of sits at the head of the
table whatever gets the best laughs he
starts
you know itemizing all the sketches and
then he goes back to his office
the cork board with the index cards
three half hour columns figures it out
you know
and then thursday through saturday
around the clock rehearsals it's like 12
hours a day so people i mean i i have
nothing but love for everybody that's
worked on the show and so many great
women and men i mean honestly i think
there have been even more great women on
the show over the years but so many
great people man so that's how it goes
it's like a six day a week job man and
when you go live when you're ready for
that saturday night live they say it
that's the rush is is that the is that
the rush literally no it literally is
like a visceral it's a rush how many
shits do you take before a show i take
at least three at least three shits
that's that's right we do this show
twice so that's six shits six ships
did you have things that were cut out of
rehearsal
well i think that's part of the
the impetus for why he does it you know
he tapes certain things like they tape
that whole show we do it twice right you
know so they bring in an audience it's
it uh what is it 7 30 8 o'clock we do
the whole show live soup to nuts top to
bottom
and then they kick that audience out
they bring another audience in and then
we do it again live amazing so it's
twice oh you know on saturday you do it
and you work you had these guest stars
come in these these big actors yeah who
was the one that you remember that you
were like oh [ __ ] look who's going to be
on snl well you know what it was all
kinds of people the year i was on it was
we had you know madonna oprah i mean it
was just all these people uh
billy martin the former manager for the
yanks
marvin hagler this is the mid-80s
marvelous yeah
who was the biggest pain in the ass
madonna had probably me at the time yeah
probably how were you a pain in the ass
well i wasn't asked back so let's just
deduce were you no i wasn't you were you
were a nice guy i was a nice guy but it
wasn't that's back ryan
but madonna but donna was cool man
madonna was great was she like i love
you i love you no none of that no no she
was super cool she was really very sexy
very
professional very serious focused
petite short very petite very short
short girl you know she was awesome
though honestly everybody was good on
the show i mean the the hosts were and
there was that thing of like they would
cater to the host we would kind of write
for the host and there was that emphasis
which was important but just the fun of
it man it's like a six day a week job
unbelievable were you hard on yourself
oh yeah you know i still am we all are
in this crazy business you know what i
mean
but like we're saying like the doing of
it was great the actual you know
everything that led up to that hour and
a half incredible man and you could have
you go could you have gone more than one
year or you just wanted to you know you
wanted to move on to be honest i don't
think lauren wanted me back i mean i i
had just
i am being honest um
no he was great i looked up to him but
you know i don't know if he felt it was
the right fit or what have you and i was
just trying to you know make my way and
i was also a wild kid we were out you
know partying throughout the week you
were a partier
you're a party well i think as a kid i
definitely was probably boozing it up
more than i should have oh i think i
think we all did yeah ryan are you doing
it now i'm doing it now in her youth
currently now before you before again
ryan you micro dose before show or
microdoses before every podcast we do i
do i do six shits and six shots before
every uh every six ships six shots
for the show now before all this
happened like if we go way back i mean
you were like the honeycomb kid
you were doing commercials i mean
seriously yeah you were doing like were
you was your mother surprised because
she was a singer by the way do you sing
i do make music i have it in years but i
love to make music i play a little
guitar and bass and you know why don't
you ever record something i did years
ago and i'm actually working with a guy
with a business partner named jason
maris a great guy and we are working on
stuff we actually just produced a song
we sold to uh machine gun kelly actually
so get out yeah yeah yeah so i'm working
on music still and you sing you're
singing in the song right now well yeah
i am yeah but right now we're just kind
of tracking stuff and he's really good
he's this guy's had like thirty five top
one hits he's written for the weekend a
lot of people he's great so that's fun i
still like doing it you know yeah of
course man i think i always wanted to be
a rock star and i was always like yeah
you don't have the voice you don't have
the musicianship and then one day i said
[ __ ] it why am i so worried about
everybody else you know
why don't i just do it yeah and it has
been the best most amazing experience to
just make a cd great make a cd make an
album
make a tape he thinks it's the 90s right
he's talking about cds
did he get rest last night what's going
on with rosenberg
a cd
i made an 8-track and i brought it to
you
but like you're doing all this stuff
what was you know and your mom's singing
and she's taking care of the family
pretty much she's supporting you she was
until she met my my father you know my
stepfather when i was about 12 and they
had my sister my sister's an incredible
artist she goes by mary c and the
stellar she has a great band in new york
city she's incredible she's a mother now
but she's an incredible artist she went
the route of making music you check her
out on youtube i said yeah yeah she's
produced about five or six albums
so i'm going to blow my sister yeah but
so i think it was just that thing
michael of like growing up in the city
man that was why i was a great teacher i
saw everything was possible
you're around so many different things
so much culture
um just the city what it represents man
it was like incredible growing up in new
york did you have
this innate confidence do you think you
had a young age that you were like you
look back and go
god i wish i had that comp because i i
do i feel like i i wish i had the
confidence i did when i was younger i
just didn't take no for an answer i
didn't give a [ __ ] that's it yeah but i
think when you grow up you start to give
a [ __ ] more no that's a great point i
had the similar perspective on it as a
kid yeah you're kind of just fearless
and then you learn the craft and it
beats you up the business and you just
have to then i think you you you create
or you get to those critical
pull you know places where it's like do
i really want to do this and you have to
really decide to reinvest and keep going
but absolutely man you have to have a
thick skin you got to be determined you
got to be
kind of crazy right and those are in
that regard you know and i had that same
amount you know mindset that you did you
just you didn't care or you cared but
you just said i'm going to do my thing
yeah and i think like you said as we get
older you become more self-conscious in
some ways maybe that's all whatever but
then you kind of unlearn that stuff just
depends on the work so i just i i've
always just looked at it like you know
what no one's going to take this from me
i'm going to keep working and just keep
developing over time you know and mixing
it up because you know it is we don't
have the luxury of picking projects
necessarily it's not what people think
you know it's a lot of year-round hustle
was your mom always really proud of you
do you remember like yeah always like
you know saying hey i'm really proud of
you doing great oh no did you get that
kind of thing at home oh definitely no i
had great support from my mother my
father and my sister you know and i
think that kind of northeast
upbringing really served me well you
know and you're always funny at home too
you're always i was it was always yeah
yeah just to get out of [ __ ] or make up
for bad grades or whatever absolutely
yeah no i was a goofy kid man i was
always and popular were you popular no
no i mean well don't forget like when i
was in high school i went to work so
there was no real you know i went to
high school until about ninth grade and
then it was busy with hughes you know
what was the first one i never
experienced like popular in high school
i don't know what that was you don't
know what popular was no i don't know
but you were talking to someone who
doesn't know what popular is either
never never was popular shortest kid in
my high school didn't start puberty
until i think my junior year i got some
hair on my balls i used to pray at night
to god please give me hair on my balls
or under my armpits very nice far i
didn't get that does that make you
uncomfortable no it doesn't
no it doesn't okay good i had hair on my
balls by uh about 18 19. no 12 13.
what was the first first big role the
first thing you did
well you know what thinking back talking
about my early childhood as a kid in new
york i auditioned this is how old i am
on golden pond you auditioned for on
golden pond was this movie like 1980
yeah 80 78 right so that i was about
eight years old i'm in this game 45
years man
wow yeah and i remember not getting the
part and i had a great exchange with
mark rydell who was so cool even to me
as a little kid
because i remember him breaking the news
to me and basically said him it's not
going to work out and they hired doug
mckean who was the kid in the film so
that's how far i go back you know and
then i did commercials and it was just
kind of like a hobby that spun you know
into some work so the first big one to
your question was like vacation chubby
chase and what was what was that
audition like do you remember
auditioning for that i remember walking
in and meeting maddie simmons he was a
great guy uh we lost him a couple years
ago he created lampoon magazine and i
remember meeting harold ramos and maddie
on that day you went in for the first
audition yeah
yeah yeah and what was your audition do
you remember what scene i don't really
know i don't remember what scene but it
was something probably with chaby one of
the scenes maybe chevy was there no no
but was probably the scene in the desert
with chevy you know it was probably one
of those scenes i don't i don't recall
were you drinking the beer yeah it was
probably one but you didn't have you
didn't meet chevy before you got the
part no no just maddie and harold remus
so that was a big that that was really
cool what's interesting too is john
hughes actually wrote that screenplay i
didn't read him then right so
his trajectory was interesting he
started selling short stories to lampoon
magazine right he had been a copywriter
in chicago he wrote and that's what
she's having a baby is that context so
kevin bacon's playing him
liz mcgovern was playing his wife and uh
so he sold this short story next thing
you know they made it to the film i did
that film didn't know john and then
right after that i did 16 candles and
audition for them and then right as a
kid and then did three in a row with
them yeah but vacation man
that that is
i always think of like people when they
work with chevy chase because you always
hear things you hear things i've had uh
joel mchale he was on here and he talked
about greg
he loves chevy but like you know there
were some problems on set was there was
yeah on the community and things happen
and you know he got fired and all these
all these things do you remember him
being very
giving and and nurturing and kind of
like guiding you because you had to be
nervous as [ __ ] or were you not
oh i was nervous yeah as a kid
absolutely by the time i did community
no i had a different take on it but i
had a great time on that show i mean
there were so many great actors on that
show all the all the whole cast was cool
and um
i you know i worked with him briefly on
that yeah
though i'm talking about video on
vacation i mean i was just i was rusty i
was 14 years old so i looked up to
everybody man you know john john candy
was great john candy really was
a big personality and a lot of fun what
was it about him well chevy was kind of
like the way he is kind of snarky and
funny you know what i mean but candy was
uncle buck man he was really and the way
it happened was we shot one ending it
didn't work and it was that thing where
the studio tested it they got the cards
back and they realized
from the original ending that they never
made it to wally world so we regrouped
six months later puberty kicked it i'm
like four inches taller i get to the set
at magic mountain i got a huge zit on my
chin chevy's like nice okay you're
jerking off good to see you've grown uh
it was just probably but that's how
chevy was yeah yeah no he said uh yeah
something like that if you're blind
you're doing it right meaning i was
wacking off i don't know what up dally
was saying
um and then they hired john candy and
that's the ending we shot that they used
so the test screening came back and the
audience was like [ __ ] we want to see
them make it to wally world they never
did so that's not what happened then we
reached out the ending and we did it did
you think the movie was going to be i
mean you hear this all the time you have
no idea you never know i think anybody
who says that they knew when they were
making something i i think that that's a
i think that's bs you never really know
i mean i had a great time and i was
working with all these legends you know
but as a kid i wasn't processing the
future successive or anything were you
on to the next thing while you're
already finished well 16 candles so then
back in new york i'm like in ninth grade
i get the audition for 16 candles i go
and meet john and jackie birch the
casting director who uh who really you
know put me on as they say and i did
those three films i got 16 candles after
about 10 auditions
wait wait wait wait
10 auditions i know honestly at that
time i remember doing that many there
was a bunch
and
you don't have that thing of like when
they're trying to pair people off if
they're close to hiring you they'll
bring you back in and they'll kind of
mix and match you with yeah
so that was that kind of thing
so that was cool and then i got that and
then right after that we did the other
two consecutively did you test screen
with molly or wait wait no no no it was
no screen testing on that film it was
just rounds of auditions and they would
have executives in and i i was kind of
honored because every time i came back
in the room there'd be like three more
executives from universally it was like
by the last auditions there was like
eight people in the room so who were
some of the other kids who were up for
that part i don't recall i you know
what's so funny in the interim i've read
that jim carrey did uh and i don't
remember meeting him i love jim carrey
but i never i don't remember meeting him
but i think he was up that's how old we
are that's great
now jim carrey's a lot older than you he
is but i think he i think i read
something that he'd auditioned for which
is pretty funny was that if you love jim
carrey
by the way you do impressions don't you
not really because i i read somewhere
that you always were doing impressions
when you were in snl you did impressions
i can't remember if we did anybody we
did a sketch where
i think we did the kennedys and i think
that was kind of funny you played john f
kennedy i played robert i think uh who
played jfk
i forget who played jfk but i think
randy quaid played lyndon johnson
madonna was playing maryland
and then downey i forget who downey was
playing but yeah and the kennedy's here
i think i did one of them ask not but
your country i don't know what i thought
that was i i can hear that's that right
there well that's the boston the boston
because you're from boston yeah yeah but
other than that i'm not like you know
rich little i saw rich little bit or
something about it
wait he's still alive he's still alive i
just saw him rich little was he funny
well he was great he was great how old
is rich little he's 114. is he 114 well
though he asked about you
he asked about me 16 candles obviously
was that that's the movie that really
took took things off for you i mean that
was it did man it did you know because
so i can't imagine what it's like to be
15 16 years old and you're just becoming
a star i mean how did you keep i
couldn't eat right i couldn't either man
it was a trip it was it's like
everything you do at that point yeah so
i read somewhere like you were the
fourth most uh they said the fourth best
teen actor of all time you were ranked
on this list of 200 teenagers and they
said you were number four i don't know
how you weren't number one what was that
like a vh1 contest what was it i don't
know what it was wow but i'm telling you
it seems like everything you touched
turned to gold it was mostly huge honest
to god michael he was great you know he
had these parties set up the scripts
were great there were always a nice sort
of equal distribution of fun stuff for
us to do and just the way he worked man
he gave us all those great opportunities
and like i said he was very cool with
like collaborating trying stuff he was
always kind of conspiring with the
actors to make it funnier
and uh you know in a similar way david
gordon green same thing man very natural
talented writer
great director not sticklers not
sticklers great perfect word you know
really open to the process and fluid and
let things happen which is cool and i
think when when directors are like that
as you know you're gonna you're gonna go
that much further for the director man
you're gonna do you know yeah give it
your all so that's the environment that
he created michael that's why it was
great have you had experiences where you
you don't get that freedom man or you
just like no say it by the way well you
know how it is yeah without naming names
you know you do movies or even tv shows
man and you don't necessarily always get
that vibe from directors and i've worked
with a lot of great directors and some
okay you know some great tv directors
you know um
and you know you're always learning but
some of them are more
you know subdued than others or they
might work from the monitor you know
just just get a variance of different
things with different people
inside of you is brought to you by
geico folks ryan do you uh own or rent
your own home i rent my home do you want
to rent your home i own my own home wow
and uh it could be a lot of work it's a
lot of work for both of us i mean
whether you're running a home or owning
a home it's it's it's the toughest parts
the toughest bills to pay it's a pain in
the arse but you know it's easy ryan
bundling with geico you're damn right
bundling policies with geico geico folks
makes it easy to bundle your homeowners
or renters insurance along with your
auto policy it's a good thing too
because you already have so much to do
around your house or your apartment and
you just want to be able to pay all this
in one fell swoop you know what i mean
it's just make it easy on yourselves
make it easy go to geico.com
get a quote and see how much you could
save it's skyco easy visit geico.com
today that's geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by helix
sleep how many people out there don't
sleep well
how many people out there
understand that sleep is the most
important thing you can do in your life
it truly is you sleep most of your life
so if you're not comfortable if you're
not getting a good night's sleep i don't
know what the hell to tell you helix
sleep
is the chisel nizzle
okay that's the word i'm going to use
right now ryan
let's the shizzle
comfort i have back problems i have neck
problems with helix i am comfortable i
feel like i have a good night's sleep it
helps me there are a few matches out
at mattresses out there that help me and
i just uh i really like what helix is
doing
and why don't you tell them what they
could do and what they have to do to get
a helix sleep mattress helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete two minutes and it matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you so why would
you buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep everybody's unique ryan
you me and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have the soft the
medium and firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot and even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers i took the helix quiz
i'm a medium guy you know it's like
porridge you know just right that's
what's right for me
and i'd say it's been awesome getting
messages from you folks uh who also
found out the helix matrix mattress of
your dreams my good buddy jeff i'll just
say jeff d emailed me and said hey
what's that code for uh for helix
mattress and i just sent it to him
yesterday swear to god and he just
bought a helix mattress and i'm pumped
that even my friends are buying them
because they believe me when i talk
about it they know that that with all my
back problems i i don't bs so look if
you're looking for a mattress just take
a quiz it's a quick quiz even i could
pass it uh you order the mattress that
you're matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free you
don't ever need to go to the mattress
store ever again helix is awesome but
you don't need to take my word for it it
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 and by gq and
wired magazine and here's all you have
to do just go to helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com inside take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life and they
have a 10 year warranty and you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at
helixsleep.com
inside that's helix sleep.com
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillars
that's pillows in my term inside of you
is brought to you by
better help what would we do without
better help ryan are you still doing the
better help still doing the better help
and is it helping it is helping i love
it i love it i think you know we're in
such a climate
and i think the climate's always been
there there's always been stressful
times for people there's always it's not
like life gets any easier it's just like
how do we make life easier
and that's better help better help the
folks at betterhelp can really help you
whether you're struggling with grief
relationships or stress or you're having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you it's for me
it's for ryan it's for millions and
millions of people around the world it
helps you live a better life better help
is secure online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with licensed professional therapists
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own accredited
therapist you can start communicating in
under 48 hours
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist how easy is that you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available i'll tell you
know therapists in los angeles can cost
hundreds and hundreds of dollars and
better help is just a great option
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help that
they're recruiting additional therapists
in all 50 states
um
i just love better help i they've been a
sponsor for a long time and they're
helping a lot of people and i want to
thank betterhelp
inside you is sponsored by betterhelp
and our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash inside try better help many of
my friends have texted me and said does
this really work
and they seem to have figured out that
it does
so check out betterhelp and get that
discount
betterhelp.com
inside
well they say like i've read you i'm
sure you've heard this story a million
times but that john was really upset
when you didn't take ferris bueller and
you didn't take uh
what's the other one pre uh pretty pink
yeah and he was really upset and you you
the friendship was sort of severed for a
while is that true you know what
happened mike when i was promoting
hollywood kills uh halloween kills in
new york a couple weeks back i had a
nice conversation with a guy to magazine
and then this this headline hit and i'll
tell you what happened
for years i kind of opted not to tell
the story but the truth is i he did
write those two projects for me he
wanted me to do them at the time he was
going to have howie deutch was a great
guy you know howie um
i worked with his wife leah thompson he
was going to direct pretty in pink and
he wanted me to star in ferris bueller
and i was actually booked and busy on
some other projects so it just didn't
work out and i think that kind of broke
john hughes's heart it broke mine too
because i really wanted to continue that
relationship yeah so that's how it
happened man you know and then years
later the last time i talked to him um
he called me with john candy on the
phone
it was incredible man we hung out like
this for a couple hours and just you
know shot the [ __ ]
and he talked about the potential for
like a breakfast club sequel and all
these things were in his eyes you know
in his
in his thinking at that time um
but he was just the greatest man i love
him we were always laughing he'd take us
to blues bars we'd go to record stores
you know we'd go and hang out at his
house
i mean what he did for me he did for so
many you know so many so it's not like
just you know right right you know the
dylan there's so many great actors and
actresses and he was just putting us on
the map and giving us opportunity man
did he throw [ __ ] at you like
hey mike tr try try this add this line
right here oh totally do this
just go off on this yeah no no no we
would talk it out between takes i would
run to the sidelines and get you know
his input and oh no dude we were always
doing that man what's a scene that you
remember or scenes that just elevated so
that you were like when you first
started filming it it was like okay this
is kind of funny yeah but it just became
something way funny okay perfect example
this is a true story i'm guessing the
car scene well let's go back to you
there's one of them i got one for that
too so watch this we're shooting 16
candles i'm 15 years old i look 12 like
a bobblehead
and
i remember we're casting we're in
chicago and we're doing the casting
rounds for the guys who are going to
play my buddy
my two buddies so hughes turns to me i
swear to you i'm 15 years old he goes
well to your buddies you got i'm gonna
let you cast them i was like what what
so i cast cusack i don't even know if
cusack knows this call me john you cast
john i swear to you because john hughes
said so i was like i can't i couldn't
believe it either and then this other
guy darren who played the other sidekick
who was hilarious
so back to the scene work i mean that
scene at the high school dance for
example just coming up with [ __ ] like
smacking them in the face you know
you turning around when you're like all
of that [ __ ] all of that all that shit's
all you yeah well no because he cut me
loose because he would we would come up
we would talk about it and then he would
go go surprise him and do that this time
you know or goofy [ __ ] like we do the
party scene later after the after the
party the house party
and we go on set for blocking and it's
the scene after uh with michael
shoveling right after the party's over
right in the kitchen well there's that
one too but watch we go to the living
room oh yeah yeah and he sees and he's
there's like a clear coffee table there
so john goes do you think he could fit
on the team i go watch this boss and i
go under the table and that became the
thing under the table right the thing
the thing in the kitchen is another one
we get to the set we're shooting in the
kitchen it's like 2 a.m it's one of
these you're going to be funny at like 2
a.m right so we get there there's an
apron some peanuts he goes why don't you
throw the apron great then i'm eating
peanuts and then he even set the scene
he goes i'm gonna get sinatra's
strangers in the night we're gonna set
this all up i mean dude it was like that
so perfect example we would just wing it
we would just come up with [ __ ] and make
ourselves laugh and that was the other
thing too man he was always
truly going for the laugh
and if something came up he he was
always laughing like in my mind's eye
when i think about both of them
both hughes and harold ramus the joy the
happiness they worked with man they were
fun they were always doing that rare
thing right
get it and then they get the comedy and
not only that but they get you
right they get you and they want you to
be your best and they go well we've got
a gold mine here we can get anything
because you really at that time in your
life you you it seems like you could do
anything you could make were you making
the whole cast laugh constantly it was
well there was that that was fun too it
really was the idea of having fun at
work and making him who was the easier
easiest to like make laugh who did you
get to laugh the most well honestly i
only remember thinking about making him
laugh but i remember that feeling of
like again back to making the crew of
your audience you have fun with it man
but i remember wanting to make him laugh
all the time because we were always
working at this level where it was just
like
partly improved you know but we would
always shoot it as per first you know
what i mean so when you're under that
table and 16 cameras that what did you
say did you say it was a chain yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah and the voice cracking that was all
real that was all it just wasn't written
no
just little [ __ ] and you go home feeling
so great like oh my god i made everybody
laugh today i'm having so much fun today
exactly and then you grow up and you
start to do roles where it's like it's
not as fun
it's just not as fun that happened too
to be very honest absolutely by the way
that made me appreciate how great he was
because all these years later no one was
like him and in fairness in fairness i
would say remus too harold remus was
just brilliant he was such a great guy
yeah so i could i can see that when i
think back i can just see them smiling
and laughing because that's how they
worked man they were great was on i
don't talk too much about this but like
in breakfast club paul gleason oh he was
great the late great paul gleason was he
honestly great or did he want to
personify that dick arrogant guy that so
he tried to stay away from you tell me
about let me tell you how this happened
okay so at the time trading places was
in theaters huge eddie murphy fam still
i love eddie murphy
he was interviewing and auditioning the
guy that played coach on cheers remember
the actor
he was awesome hilarious so then i go
see trading places i come to the set the
next day go john you go see this movie
there's a scene in training places
you remember this when paul gliese is at
a phone booth and like a 95 year old
woman comes up to him and she's what
remember phone booth's wrong she comes
up to him she go and look she's waiting
for the thing and he puts the phone that
goes [ __ ] off to the old lady
so dude i came back to the set
i came back to the set and i told john
about that he wound up seeing the film
and he brought pauline so it was because
i'd seen trading places and then he we
just both so you cast puglies no no i
didn't cast gleeson but i i gave him
that gave him that i did i did i threw
that at him and then we became friends
man we became buddies you know i met
tyson through paul gleason went to
fights and hung out paul gleason was
great man he had two heroes mickey
mantle and dylan wow yeah so paul
gleason and i were buddies i mean so
many great friends i met bro like
yourself over the years bill paxton the
late great billboard what about tyson
you became friends with tyson became
friends with touch how old 18. we went
to the fight at the garden i meet tyson
he's like just about to become champion
and uh
this was funny man he knocks this guy
out in like four seconds wait was that
sphynx no no it wasn't spanx it was way
before that i forget the guy's name it
was a garden fight again about a year
before he became champion so tyson's
about 19.
knocks this guy out
and then he knew gleason so i see tyson
come out of the ring and me and gleason
are sitting there ringside
and he weighs me over and he goes i'm
great am i have your work and i was like
so that night i hung out with with tyson
and gleason and uh
we became friends
i love i just want a second about time i
love this i love these stories this good
stuff this is great this is great so
tyson i gotta say i just love seeing
where he's at now right i mean he's got
cannabis business and he's promoting
concerts i'm just happy and he's really
a bunch of kids a great wife he is man
he just really tells it how it is you
just like this is what i believe and
this is what i'm going to say yeah it's
it is it's amazing it really is so i'm
really happy for i haven't seen mike in
years but um so yeah i mean these great
stories were there anybody on the
breakfast club that you really did i
mean you didn't love working with or
whether it was everybody just great oh
no we all got along it was cool but what
was funny at the time was me and molly
were kids man we were 16 so we had like
homework we had to go back to the hotel
see the skokie hilton or whatever the
[ __ ] it was
and then judd and emilia would go out
and hang out they'd go out beers and
whatever because they were like you know
i don't know 35 when they did the film
no no they were in their early 20s
so molly and i had homework and jutted
out and emilia hung out but we loved
each other man we all got along great i
looked up to all of them to this day i
loved it do you still talk to them ever
i haven't spoken i ran into judd a
couple years ago he's great he's got a
great sense of humor man judd's funny
amelo i haven't seen that much um ali
i've seen over the years the last time
we were all reunited is when mr hughes
passed 2010 man we had the oscar thing
where they paid tribute tonight
so i thought that was very classy of the
oscars to do that because you know they
don't often
you know acknowledge comedies as it was
right but molly you still every once in
a while it's been a while since you
talked to her yeah no it's been a couple
of years since i've spoken to her but
she's cool very happily marriage had a
bunch of kids she's doing great you know
uh the janitor um oh capitalist
capitalist yeah john capitalist a great
guy he was i did the show a couple years
back and he was a guest star and we hit
it off yeah and he came over and karaoke
with his girlfriend oh greg came to the
house at karaoke what a funny guy he is
he is so watch this i produced a film
this summer with a writer director named
nick celotzi and it's not a remake but
it's an updated kind of reimagining of
the breakfast club anyway we got we got
capitalism
oh wow so capitals showed up he's a
great guy so uh
and a great comedic actor he's great now
how do you go from john hughes to tim
burton
now tim burton seems like it's got to be
he's i'm sure he's a great guy he is but
it's got to be a different way of
working well at the time when that came
up this is edward scissorhands yeah 1989
man uh so i went to go meet with him
and tim you remember the remember the
cure he looked like a lost member of the
cure right he had the hair and yes yeah
i remember when i went to his office
smith yeah yeah robert smith he had the
leg up in the chair and
he was kind of twirling his hair and
[ __ ] and
really interesting guy very shy actually
i'm very unassuming and very cool
and but he really comes to life when he
directs so
he hired me for scissorhands i
auditioned for him in a room and and
that was a great experience too man um
okay i have a theory about tim burton
i think he is edward scissorhands
here's what i'll explain please do okay
i'll explain
he grew up in in burbank he was a
student of animation his favorite actor
was vincent price right
and
just i i look at him like a modern-day
disney and beyond i mean you look at his
films their works of art man yeah and
he's one of those [ __ ] you know like
rare
auteurs great directors where he really
has a look and feel with his movies
and they get
more and more brilliant since then right
i mean he went on to do another seven
movies or whatever with johnny depp
right yeah so i just love tim burton man
and i think at the time he felt
i think he probably thought it was kind
of funny because i had sprouted up and
it was a bigger guy yeah you know and
johnny was like you know
uh you know to play that bully i think
he kind of thought it was a fun idea at
the time so great experience we shot in
tampa florida at the time johnny was
with winona and they were in love and
all that
did you meet vincent price i didn't get
to work with vincent price no i know
those great actresses kathy bates all
these all these women that were in the
film were fantastic and
uh that was another great experience i
had fun on that one and another other
roles i hear that you turned down like
did you ever meet with stanley kubrick
on full metal jacket i did man you met
with stanley i didn't meet with him but
i had a couple calls with him it's an
interesting story so
i'm doing weird science and i get a call
from my agent a gentleman named marty
bauer it's a great guy
uh marty started the bauer benedict
agency which became another big agency i
think uta right
so as a kid he represented me he was
like family i love marty so he calls me
like on a wednesday he says
stanley kubrick is interested in you in
this uh for a role in this vietnam
biopic he's doing and i was like holy
[ __ ] because even at 17 i'd seen the
shiny and all these great movies oh yeah
so i get a call friday two days later he
goes well he's actually wants you for
the lead and he wants to call you
tomorrow
mike dropped right i'm like holy [ __ ]
why aren't you trying to call me
it's like wait for the wizard of oz
right
so the next morning the phone rings
and i'm like up at pace i'm at the
sheraton premiere by the universal city
and i'm up like pacing like i'm just wet
going i can't believe i'm talking how
old are you i'm 18.
uh the phone rings michael stanley
kubrick i was like dude
and then this is what he said to me he
paid me the greatest compliment i've
ever had he goes like i just finished uh
screening 16 candles i watched it three
times i couldn't believe it i'm just
sitting here and he goes like uh you
know you're my favorite actor since i
saw jack an easy rider i was like dude
i'm a kid yeah no exactly he said that
to me so that it was amazing it was
astonishing michael it was
and then even more you know beyond that
wonderful compliment he wound up talking
about his favorite filmmakers he started
talking about eisenstein the great
russian director and chaplain and
dude and you're just sitting there
listening i'm standing there in the
sheridan premiere like looking over the
valley like in my window
and i was just bugging out it was
incredible so
what happened was it became literally
like an eight or nine month negotiation
and holy [ __ ] yeah and it was you know
it was i could say in hindsight it was
about money but it wasn't it was just a
crazy drawn out thing
he was incredibly private i had to go to
his attorney's house in beverly hills
and read a numbered script i mean
literally dude it was like this wow
and you know for whatever reason didn't
work out and and
and that's another great film of his so
i mean i wouldn't have any regrets in my
life i don't but in terms of a creative
thing that's probably the closest thing
that it just breaks my heart sometimes
that it didn't work out i needed to work
with him but right uh do you think maybe
the agents got in the way
no no no no it wasn't even like that it
was just we just kind of parted ways but
i couldn't believe it took that long at
one point nine months no no i swear to
you at one point he called his lawyer
and his lawyer called my father who was
a great manager
he discovered like azamo and sandra
bullock and all these people who's a
great manager tom
and the question that louis blau had for
my father was
mr kubrick wants to know if tom has read
nuclear negotiations
a book called nuclear
kubrick was deep dude everything was
chess everything was nuclear
i swear i swear to you so
so anyway i mean i i would have loved to
have done that and then it's funny
little epilogue i run into matthew
modine a couple years later
in new york city and i'm still a kid you
know and he was he was kind of big
league of me he was funny
how you doing modena cool
and then i started walking alongside him
in new york and we're talking i go so
how long do you guys wind up shooting
that film you know
tell me vision quest i want to know
and uh he goes i swear to good he goes
54 weeks
54 weeks he shot for a year and two
weeks wow but he was just brilliant and
he had that
capacity and and that allowance within
our industry i mean the very few people
how long and should have filmed that
long i think not since chaplain you know
because chaplain was notorious that in
that day of the max senate days he would
shoot something and if he ran out of
ideas he would just break camp you know
right and chaplain would notify you when
he had some ideas for stunts you know
but stanley cooper what can i say man i
just bowed out i love stealing kubrick
so i look i'm grateful for that whole
what was your next project while you
were you were filming while that was
taking place johnny be good nice choice
huh no i actually enjoyed johnny be good
did you not like that movie no no i had
a good time on him i'm just joking down
he refers to it as johnny b movie
is that what he says but i had a great
time at a good time but it's got to be
hard like you know it's like you've
talked about this a million times but
like transitioning
yeah yeah how do you transition from the
biggest movie star as a teenager and
then as an adult i mean how how often
and that's the thing you did yeah no
that was the thing you know and the
truth is you know how it is man you have
up and down periods you got to be in it
for the long haul you know downey's
senior
downy senior used to joke with me as a
punt on my name robert's father he goes
in the long haul the short one won't
make it
which is pretty funny but that's the
thing you know i had no idea man about a
career i didn't know what the hell i was
doing i was just a kid but these were
the experiences i had so yeah incredible
man by the way i i one thing i gotta say
is like
how old are you when you do weird
science 17
how do you not hit on kelly lebrock oh
she was amazing beautiful woman we're
still friends at the stage she's like
really she's a lot of fun
i mean that had to be an amazing
experience working with her she was cool
because every kid because i'm your age
pretty much and i'm watching going holy
[ __ ] well here's what happened at the
time there was another person hired a
lady named kelly ember who was also a
beautiful supermodel
and unfortunately it just wasn't working
out we shot for a couple days and then
and then that didn't work out
so then they brought kelly and she had
done woman in red and kelly replaced
kelly you know
um and she was great man as the british
say she takes the piss out of everybody
she's great she's super cool and you
were improvising in that movie oh yeah i
mean that whole scene where you like
call her on the telephone yeah yeah yeah
no that was another one
yeah and john set that up and then
that kind of stemmed from being a huge
fan of prior i would imitate prior for
hughes i would listen like we would go
to his house and then hang out with his
wife and his kids and i'm like a
teenager
and we would watch everything from
advent costello to the you know laurel
and hardy to live on sunset strip or
whatever right right so it kind of
stemmed from
that would be like an inside joke with
me and hughes i would imitate this
character that prior did called mud bone
and mud bones how did he sound
go outside and get some sunshine on your
face why you know he was just like this
whole
character and that's kind of who you
modeled that character totally the great
richard pryor so that would make the i
just would have called it on the
telephone on the telephone yeah exactly
so i would just goof and
it was just one of the funniest scenes
ever thank you bro it was just a love of
prior honestly just immediately
yeah yeah and he just said keep going
with it well some of that was scripted i
think he had some of the lines about the
girl [ __ ] need me in the nuts and all
that
my nuts are halfway up my [ __ ] but
otherwise perfect yeah yeah yeah i don't
think i looked but he was great like
that so he kind of set that scene and we
just you know what's that what's your
favorite if you had to look back at one
part if you just could only take one
part that you've done
oh i don't know if i could do that yeah
if you think one part
my favorite uh this movie halloween
kills man
you like that segway i like it but by
the way i've never been more pumped
honest to god i've never been more
excited but i think everybody's pumped
about this movie i really think that
it's just like it's kicking ass right
now and where can we watch it
okay it's in theaters number one movie
in the country uh i think we got bumped
this weekend by dune which did great
but it's made over like 90 million
worldwide in 10 days by the way i bet
it's a lot shorter than dune
was doing a week it was a long movie did
it take nine hours it was two hours and
40 minutes it was a good it was a good
movie but i'm just saying halloween's
something you probably watch it's not
that it's not it looks good i want to
see dune no halloween kicks ass it's an
hour and 45 minutes and it's just a
[ __ ] roller coaster i mean it is and
how's jamie the curtis she's awesome is
she really i hear she's awesome no no
she really is i mean when i think of
jamie like i was in love her as a kid
man when i first saw the first one
trading places i always loved jamie
curtis i had a huge crush on her i met
her and her great husband when when i
was a kid chris guest another genius i
love this guy man chris guest oh he's
genius he really is he loves what's
going on maybe he's a goffman oh do
everything right best in show yeah so i
had the pleasure of meeting them when i
was a kid um but she's awesome she's
super chill and down to earth and you
know has a great heart she has this
non-profit called my hand and yours
right and sh which benefits children's
hospital of la and she's just a cool
lady you know she's got they have a
couple of kids and
you know she's writing a project i think
she's going to direct a film with jason
plums company plum house she's going to
put you in it i hope so man but she's
awesome she really is she has a lot of
heart and really cares about people man
you can really see it it cuts through
you know well you do pretty much in
terms of i'm not saying everything but
you'll if you like a script or if you
like a project you'll do it whether it's
horror whether it's comedy whether it's
drama you just have to like it but you
you love to work i do man i do and i
like mixing it up i think one of the
things i've
i've enjoyed just watching some of the
greats that we both admired i'm sure
growing up man like i love ben kingsley
for example oh yeah like sir ben
kingsley man i'll go light to dark right
like house of sand and fog and then
sexy beast right oh my god yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yes amazing he's incredible i could see
you playing an absolute psychopath like
really i have i mean
what
i did this movie called war machine a
couple years ago it was with brad pitt
that was a lot of fun i played a general
i mean it was based on oh you did play a
psycho yeah well well he was a tough
general was a crazy gen i mean i that
was just my choice you know we were
playing real generals but
it was in part fictionalized it was a
project that brad's company produced
um it was based on a book called the
operators great project you know so that
was fun so i played kind of i played my
general kind of like a jar head like he
was a marine general or something so i
mean i've had a lot of fun playing
villains you know
empires of silicon valley though i i
just remember watching how you
transformed yourself into bill gates
thanks man and i just it just it blew me
away it's really have you ever seen it
ryan no what the [ __ ] no i mean you
could you won't believe it it's one of
those things when you watch you're like
because i think you were nominated for
it weren't you
yeah i appreciate it no the film was it
was nominated for five emmys i think it
was great experience man yeah noah wiley
great guy to work with he really looked
like steve jobs too man he was great
would you do anything for a role in
terms of gaining 30 pounds losing 20
pounds what i kind of did for halloween
kills man i was just in the south i mean
i was trying to hit the gym i was in
there every morning for about a half
hour
really just
but then but then i was eating like an
animal man a good old southern food you
have to yeah but it kind of worked for
that too and i decided to shave my head
which is no i'm sticking with this
haircut because no it looks good thanks
man so uh
no for that yeah i wanted to kind of
just beef up a little bit but i was
eating good man north carolina was fun
all right this is called [ __ ] talk and
this is the kind of the end of the
interview where it's [ __ ] talking with
anthony michael hall
uh my patrons my lovable patrons they
get to ask some questions grace you
answer them let's do it man yeah leanne
really loved your character on the
goldbergs any behind the scene pranks
funny moments you would like to share
well just wendy macleod uh wendy what
was her i'm sorry wendy mcclendon
did you have to ask man forget it
forgive me wendy brilliant comedic
actress she's the i mean she carries the
show but um
jeff garland all those people are
fantastic we lost mr siegel he was
brilliant but everybody all the kids on
the show i love doing that show and it's
a lot of fun too kind of poking fun of
the 80s the writing is great i have a
great time on it so
they brought me on to do us an episode
it was a goof it was a spoof of vacation
right the joke was that rusty was now a
security guard at disneyland
that was perfect
and then after that they brought me on
as a i'm a guidance counselor mr peratt
so i've done about six episodes now i
think i'm doing another one this month
so you've got a good stuff for humor you
you could easily play
make fun of yourself that's that's key
man that is key what did you say to me
when i got here if you can't do that
that's it that's it and that show gave
me a great opportunity to do that
because it's great it makes fun of
everything 80s which is great i love it
steph a who was the most similar to
their character in breakfast club
at the time maybe ringwald
really maybe
dave p any 80s brat pack movie you'd
like to see modernized
um
i don't think it would work yeah i can't
speak the first thought i had was not
any of john's films it was i actually
thought of fast times but you couldn't
remake that remember how great sean was
on that movie come on dude it was all
the characters mr hand you dick you did
you knock when you enter curtis
remember
entree i'm gonna go over to london and
party with mick and keith dude that one
is great that movie is a great movie
yeah and i love when what's her name's
phoebe cates comes out of the pool and
he's jerking off in the
another great moment yes carly to your
relationship with johnny that's mrs
kevin kline to you okay
i'm sorry i apologize
uh you know we're carly we already know
me too all the [ __ ] happened
michelle k who is the one person you
would love to work with again
downey
we have something that we're writing
uh a project and working with he and his
wife last couple years is great so we're
still working on it we're still working
on we have a tv show that we wrote
actually i would love that what's the tv
show you can't tell what it's about i
can't i can't you know it's interesting
because it's it's called singularity
it's a lot of fun um and it's something
we've been working on it's hopefully
we'll bring it to air dana asked super
geeked with you this guy super dana's
super geeked on you the new hollywood
the new movie halloween kills being up
front with michael myers was that face
scary as hell or what as a child up to
right now he still freaks me out yeah
was it even scary while you were acting
it wasn't scary it wasn't scary but i
mean we have such great let me just talk
about the crew for a second this guy
chris nelson christopher nelson designs
the mask he's awesome james jude corte
is a great guy but we kind of left each
other alone during the making of the
film just to kind of give each other
space so we could vibe out on the scenes
but we've become friendly since making
the film cool guy great cinematographer
we had michael simmons this guy who shot
the movie looks incredible but david
gordon green dude honestly he just
kicked so much ass this movie is like
i'm so proud of it and the fact that i
can say i'm working for danny and david
and james was danny on set he was for
the first week dude i'm a huge danny did
you guys just talk forever we did we
vibed out he was so funny you know he
said something to me in passing i was
giving him a compliment about his
comment i love him
and he goes use the force luke or some
[ __ ] like that it was hilarious he's
like use my force he said something like
that
but he's super chill he's so down on
earth yeah he's a great guy dude what a
great comedian right to me he's like the
modern-day bill murray i think he's one
of the funniest humans him and kristen
wiig are they like the two oh my god
kate mckinnon too oh yeah there's so
many good communities brilliant by the
way i i have to mention it because i'm a
big fan of six-pack from 1982 but you
work with kenny you [ __ ] lie for a
living you don't love six-pack kenny
rogers dude six people didn't like this
i love i have it on vhs you weren't
watching the family fair in 1980 i bet i
have it up here actually you were
probably like nine years old that was
like 12 when i made the film yeah do you
really remember watching the film um a
billion percent i love six packs i love
that movie kenny rogers was a great guy
man he was an awesome guy what a
sweetheart he loved us all man he was so
cool did he ever play guitar for you and
sit there and sing to you no but he had
like he would he would take us up and
helicopter rides and he had the wrap
party at his house just really great
stuff he was like really he did dude he
was awesome what a nice guy man and
diane lane in it too she's awesome
i loved her i know beautiful man
i fell in love with her i loved her when
i was a kid remember a little romance
that movie yes yes
i think that was the first you know
diane lane yeah
what was that movie where he doesn't
know anything before 2012
what is he 21 how old is this kid what
was the movie where richard
kills the guy that she's having an
affair with
do you remember that one no no no was it
uh oh my god
dark movies with richard gere you have
to see that it is an amazing turn of
events and she is
drop dead gorgeous still is beautiful
woman yeah that's a really nice person
too by the way
you know everybody always asks this
question it's not like you would [ __ ]
know you wouldn't know the answer i
don't know much but michael scheffling
the most gorgeous guy in the history of
cinema who does one role in 16 candles
the the heartthrob hunk and then he
disappears and he moves to the east
coast to be a carpenter literally he's
like he was like the jd salinger of
actors great guy we were great friends
we actually hung out a lot he was a cool
dude man and i i miss him i haven't seen
him since and everyone want to give him
and say what are you doing
dude i actually met one of his kids his
you know he he was cool he was such a
good guy he did vision quests with
matthew mcd and then after that he just
took another one he just went another
round man
great guy never heard from him again
never heard from him again
no he literally did a salinger i think
he did i just but that takes balls to be
in a [ __ ] absolute hit of a movie
being the heartthrob and saying i'm
walking oh totally i couldn't have done
that could you have done that no i don't
think no i obviously obviously didn't i
obviously didn't do it i've tried making
furniture right it doesn't really work
yeah man that always always baffles but
he was super a great guy man he really
was we were like buddies
it was funny because i was such a young
kid but
he and i hung out all through the making
of the film when we weren't shooting
isn't that great yeah and then hugh same
thing hughes was 35 years old man at the
time and i was 15 and we were like br
best friends i honestly got it was the
best he was awesome yeah he really was
man
halloween kills it's everywhere it's out
in theaters you've got peacock you gotta
go see it's on peacock it's on the cac
it's on the [ __ ] guys
uh you gotta see it it's halloween what
else are you gonna do with your lives
this is what we do we watch horror
movies during the month of october i
know you're going to see halloween kills
and also let me just say a personal
thank you to everybody who's seen it
because people are seeing it like three
four or five times i mean it's amazing
it's almost it's over 90 million bucks
in like 10 days so it's very humbling
really exciting well i'm super happy for
you thanks and you deserve it you've
done such a
great amount of work you got such a
great body of work thank you brother i
want to see you continue i mean we
didn't even talk about the dead zone we
didn't talk about so many projects great
projects do it again yeah but uh you
know love to work with you sometimes
likewise man it would be a lot of fun
and thank you uh anthony michael hall
for allowing me to be inside of you
today on the podcast good to be with you
and i know you you listen to the podcast
i appreciate it i'm a fan we've known
each other for years yeah it's a great
guy i'm happy for your success you're
doing great thanks man thanks for being
here appreciate it
i really enjoyed that that interview
he i mean talk about scheffling the guy
who played jake and 16 candles and what
he's doing and that they used to hang
out and
how he imp anthony uh michael hall
improvised and uh on different sets with
john hughes and just the great
relationship they had just uh just a far
out far out story yeah would you enjoy
about it he seemed to be acutely aware
that i was right next to him
he did he acknowledged you he
acknowledged your presence quite
frequently
it was like him and rooker it was a very
similar yes they like to they like to
sass you so does bobby lee bobby lee
it's leah yeah people like to sass you
yeah but very close to them and it's a
little unnerving yeah i understand yeah
you're close to the guest i mean not
that close you're a couple of feet but
uh nonetheless you still need my notepad
uh another shout out to our stage at
coming up if you want to hear me play
some music the album is out sun spin is
the band you can go to sunspin.com we're
playing november 20th virtually two
shows 2 p.m 6 p.m please uh spread the
word and show up and there's zooms to be
had and prizes and we play some good
music some covers
uh my good buddy tom lally from left on
laurel is going to join us as a guest
surprise although it's not a surprise
now
and
also if you want to um give back to
echoes of hope uh
you know there's a holiday event for
under-resourced children teens and young
adults 300 students will be supported
this december
a lot of them don't have anywhere to go
and are
missing out on a lot in life and they
could use your help and you can help
them by going to
at
our echoes of hope on social media and
uh you could give back you could donate
you could do a lot of there's a lot of
different options go to echoesofhope.org
to see more options and help those guys
out help those
fine folks out echoes of hope find
charity um also a shout out to ronald
mcdonald house and foodonfoot.org
uh other cherries that i help
oh god you okay all right you're right
see if people are listening i i could
have just blamed that on you
you know i could say you okay ryan and
they would have known but if they're
watching they told you
no
i didn't it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
coveted ryan i know you know if anyone
you're not gonna get it knock on wood
dude not gonna work right now
is that wood
this is wood all right [ __ ] man
uh
yeah
i love it and you know i think it's time
to give a shout out
to our top
tiers
we know those guys on patreon
patreon.com inside of the give back a
little more to the podcast some a lot
more to the podcast they keep it going
they help
keep this train going so here we go big
shout out and thanks again to anthony
michael hall my guest today ryan thanks
for being here with me no problem nancy
d leah s trisha f sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e brian h mama lauren g nico
p jerry w robert b jason w kristen k not
to be confused with kristen crook emilia
oh allison el raj c joshua d emily s cj
p samantha m jennifer n stacy l gen s
jamal f janelle b
kimberly e mike e eldon supremo 99 more
ramirez santiago m sarah f i love all
these people chad w leanne p janine r
maya r
maya p
maddie s belinda
n correct chris h dave h spiderman chase
sheila g
brad d ray h
tab of the team michelle k what up
michelle what up michael s talia m betsy
d
claire
uh i don't know what that is i think
that's claire i
it's it's a it's a
sideways
print it's like a parenthesis a
backslash yeah
no whatever it is
laura l
chad l rochelle nathan e marion meg k
janelle p trav l dan and big stevie w
kendall t angel m rhiannon rhiannon
rings like a bell through the night end
would you love to love her
corey k super sam coleman g dev nixon
michelle a liz i jeremy c andy t cody r
sebastian k gavinator and h david c john
b brandy d
yvore camille s bano bono
i think it's mono don't you b-a-n-o bano
maybe bano
bano the c joey m willy f christina e
adelaide in jeffrey m omar i
n design otg eugene and leah
hi eugene and leah i didn't leave you
out this time
uh
i hope it's not lee maybe it's eugene
and lee
did i did i eff it up again chris p
nikki g
corey ktb patricia marissa
maria n and bradley s
bradley
s
uh you guys really helped the podcast
out and i really appreciate you thanks
for listening today it's been a real
treat having you i hope you're enjoying
the holidays make sure you go uh watch
us on stage if you haven't seen a stage
of performance please get ticket
sunspin.com or stage.com type in sunspin
we'll be there we'll be playing
the store is available for merch at the
inside of you online store and
sunspin.com you can get t-shirts and a
bunch of stuff
um yeah there you go ryan there you go
good seeing you good seeing you too
thank you all for allowing me to be
inside of you today once again
thanks for having me uh as part of your
drive or your life or whatever that is
and uh so many emails so many uh
comments of how much the show means to
them
and it means a lot to me that you uh you
feel that way and that's why i keep
doing it so
uh thanks and uh from the hollywood
hills up in here in los angeles
california i'm michael rosenbaum i'm
brian tales
guys
keep rocking in the free world
have a good week
[Music]